azaria norte he had been looking forward
to voting today the work man is a
regular voter and likes doing his bit
for his country's future but going to
the polls today is proving strenuous
Norte he's been standing in line now for
more than three hours lezyne is very bad
it's not moving at all it's not moving
and people I guess actually inside in
here and there the policemen are not
green be awake right various tiny yeah I
don't know i don't know why they are
standing day they have to look at it and
I know what a delight is going on good
anybody can come by after four years in
office president john mahama is seeking
another term his main challenger is
veteran opposition leader nana akuffo
addo he's campaigning against widespread
corruption and a weak economy during the
last presidential elections the turnout
was almost eighty percent also this time
the queues in the capital Accra are very
long the electoral process is a bit slow
but peaceful in other parts of the
country the situation is more volatile
that is why one organization is
constantly monitoring social media
platforms at the social media tracking
center 70 volunteers check posts across
social media platforms on the lookout
for hate speech and any ancestry I ask
the West Des securities inadequate and
are calling for backup and a man has
been arrested the same report with the
same report a manager
for wielding a knife the incident is
taken care of after the team reported to
the police social media is a tool for
people to communicate is for two people
use for dialogue they won't learn about
which candidates would vote for and why
and social media creates all those
opportunity however there is a downside
to social media people can use of spread
fake news misinformation and so and so
forth so what we're doing is that we are
tracking after almost four hours of
waiting as a czarian otay his turn has
finally come and he casts his vote yes
I'm happy because I have it it is true I
won't slow the process is very nor tia
is sure that this time things will run
smoothly the results are expected within
the next three days